He asks: You talk about infusing
intelligent people with religion,
could you elaborate a bit on this?
what I pointed out is that historically
if you look at the great geniuses
of the 19th century, one thing they seem
to have in common is religious faith. A lot of
these people were not atheists. They were not just
religious, they believed that scientific research
was a form of revelation,
they called it neo-tomism.
So the idea is that engaging in scientific work,
discovering truth, placing a premium on truth,
this was all divinely ordained
essentially. And this was a motive
complex which kept them very truthful, kept
them very dedicated, kept them aligned with
objective truth. It also allowed
them to move into areas which
were socially taboo, fully cognizant of
the fact that in so doing, they were doing
god's work. This was an act of revelation
and if things had to change,
if this finding challenged some
preconceived notion, then so be it,
to do otherwise to suppress that was bad. And
this was a very powerful way of protecting
yourself against heterodoxy, and also imbuing
your life with a existential purpose, a life of
purposefulness, and a drive towards scientific
inquiry. So if you could put that back into
modern scientists, and charles murray (who was the
first to propose this thesis in a book published
in 2003 called human
accomplishment). He argues that
one of the transitions that's
taken place is that these
religious values have basically gone, they've
evaporated. And they've been replaced with
freudian freudo-marxist nihilist relativist type
values systems instead, which do not place a
premium on truth, and see truth as being something
that's expedient, and plays into power
dynamics. And on that basis, Murray
argues that this has handicapped
the innovativeness of scientists
because they're not able to pursue
truth, that they don't existentially value it,
they don't place a premium on it. And if they
substitute truth for politically
expedient lies, and there are
many instances of scientific research
where politically expedient lies dominate,
then they do anti-truth. They're coming to
conclusions which are in opposition to truth, and
that handicaps science even further. And that was
Murray's theory. So one possibility is, yes, by
making scientists more religious, by making them
more godly or spiritual, maybe you could actually
make them better scientists, in the same
way that the Victorians polymathic geniuses,
who were all deeply devoutly religious
and Thomistic, were very good scientists.
Yes, something I've been thinking
about a lot recently, is the
exclusion of us in academia, and the data
sets we can't get hold of. But the Victorian
University, until about 1871, when they tried to
change it, didn't really do that much in the way
of research. Research was
done by gentlemen scholars,
by interested working-class
amateurs like Thomas Edward the
Aberdeen Shoemaker, by people with
patrons, and by scholar-rectors...
Michael Faraday for example.
Exactly. There wasn't much in the way of
actual people doing research at universities,
because the university was just basically in the
hands of the church, and it was about educating
vicars and lawyers, and to a lesser extent,
doctors. But it was really about promoting the
ideology of society, and that was basically
religion and monarchy. And it was only
in 1871 that they got rid of a
system where in order to be a fellow,
in order to work at the university,
you had to be ordained to do that.
You had prep school headmasters that would do
research, and public school headmasters that
would do research. There wasn't anything going
on at the universities. And I think that in some
respects, we're going to move back
to that. We are moving back to that.
I hope so. It would certainly
be a more convivial arrangement.
With certain areas of research, the
university has become, to a certain extent
(particularly in social science and humanities) a
body whose purpose is to promote what used to be
Christianity, and now it's the
religion of multiculturalism.
Mercier Eliade looked at this, that left-wing
ideologies have some significant points of
commonality with Christianity in
a lot of ways, the guilt and the
shame and all this sort of thing,
and the worshipping of those who
are perceived as disempowered and all
this, the anti-Nietzschean system...
That would be Victimhood morality, the idea
that your nobility is in your Victimhood.